from it's surprising castes at a
slightly risque PG rating and its
innovative shooting style there are more
than a few things you should probably
know before you pick up your ticket to
Detective Pikachu here's all the
backgrounds you need on the world famous
Pokemon the movies unique setting and
more if you're not familiar with the
world of Pokemon you might want to brush
up before you head into detective
Pikachu known as Pocket Monsters in its
home country of Japan the series of
video games came to the United States in
1998 with pokémon red and blue for the
Nintendo Gameboy and sold more copies
and any other Game Boy game besides
Tetris these blockbuster beginnings laid
the groundwork for a massive multimedia
franchise which continued under the Game
Boy Advance all the way up to the
Nintendo switch with plenty of spin-offs
and tie-ins coming in along the way
between video games movies TV shows are
popular trading card series and more
pokemon has secured its spots as the
highest-grossing media franchise of all
time but it all starts with the games in
the main game series players take on the
roles of Pokemon trainers capturing wild
animal monster hybrids that roam the
world these weaponize pets then get used
in battles with other trainers players
encounter along their journeys as well
as competitive gym leaders elite
trainers and even evil gangs and
corporations from pokemon red and blues
Team Rocket - Pokemon Sun and Moon steam
skull but for the most part the games
have always come down to one goal
getting out on the tall grass hunting
for Pokemon and catching them or before
detective Pikachu referred to the live
action movie it was simply one of the
franchise's many spin-off video games
released in 2018 for Nintendo's 3ds
detective Pikachu broke away from the
loose narratives and gameplay of the
original games setting aside gym badges
and Pokemon catch in the focus instead
on the story of a special talking
Pikachu a type of electric Mouse that is
arguably the franchise's most famous
type of Pokemon in the game the pocket
monster teams up with a young boy Tim
Goodman who was the only person who can
understand Pikachu when he speaks
together the two team up to search for
Tim's missing father and get to the
bottom of a sinister conspiracy as Tim
detective Pikachu lets the player solve
mysteries with their own talking Pikachu
evoking adventures from the Pokemon
anime series the game received mixed
reviews but some critics noted that it
might make a better movie than video
game speaking of video games the movie
also evokes of
of pokemon yellow one of the series
first games the unique take on pokemon
red and blues based game greatly
increased the emphasis on the player's
relationship with their starter pokemon
in this case a pikachu who followed
behind you as you moves throughout the
game though there have been plenty of
animated pokemon movies over the decades
detective pikachu marks the franchise's
first live-action film adapting the
story of a relatively new game some
longtime pokemon fans were likely
curious about why this first live-action
movie would choose to focus on such a
recent story rather than continue the
adventures of ash misty and Brock from
the cartoon series or original film's
director Bob Letterman has opened up
about this decision saying he wanted
this film to be set apart from what came
before and tell a story that felt new
especially considering how many animated
films have already focused on the
adventures of Ash Ketchum
and Friends thanks to the live actors
our film noir feel and strikingly
lifelike cgi Pokemon detective Pikachu
should be able to make its mark on the
franchise with a totally fresh look and
not a lot of baggage
it will also be geared towards audiences
of both adults and children with a PG
rating setting it apart from the
typically g-rated animated films that
way parents and grown-up Pokemon
nostalgics should be able to enjoy the
movie just as much as the kids in the
crowd another round extra shot blackest
night thank you plenty of familiar faces
are featured in detective Pikachu
including actors like Bill Nighy Chris
Gear and Ken Watanabe but one performer
you might not know yet is just a Smith
who plays the leading role of Tim
Goodman taki your hallucination as an
actor Smith has a small but impressive
resume getting his start in television
before landing a supporting role in
2015's Paper Towns an adaptation of a
popular young adult novel by John Green
it's [ __ ] hard to understand the
power that's inside
pokemons after that breakout Smith found
more success when Baz Luhrmann customers
the lead in the ambitious Netflix series
the get down his largest pre Pikachu
role came in 2018 with Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom there the actor played
Franklin Webb a computer tech and hacker
who helps track the dinosaurs that have
spread across the park now with all that
buzz that Detective Pikachu is
generating it looks pretty likely that
this young actors career is set to
evolve to the next level
turtle squirtle turtleman squirtle don't
be fooled by the name of detective
Pikachu after all that's technically
just a subtitle the film also features
plenty of other Pokemon to remember and
recognize this includes creatures from
the series later generations like a palm
moral law and Emolga
but the most recognizable will likely be
some of the original 151 the three
starting Pokemon from the series first
generation Bulbasaur squirtle and
Charmander are all there as well as
other favorites such as mr. mime and
Jigglypuff just say just like in the
games many Pokemon won't be spotted out
in the wild but rather as companions to
other human characters Lucy Stevens a
reporter who helps Tim solve mysteries
in the movie is accompanied by our own
personal Pokemon a loyal Psyduck one of
the busiest aspects of Detective Pikachu
is the unexpected voice behind the
cuddly creature it's a hard thing to get
right but how do you win over audiences
with an english-speaking version of a
famous electric Mouse mostly known for
squeaking his own name well plenty of
actors might come to mind
Deadpool star Ryan Reynolds ended up
snagging the role beating out equally
off-the-wall actor choices like Hugh
Jackman Dwayne the rock Johnson and
Danny DeVito but as the trailers have
demonstrated Reynolds take on the
capable witty and slightly bewildered
detective Pikachu kind of makes sense
thanks to its dry sense of humor and
irony which viewers have proven
themselves to love so much in Deadpool
Reynolds is turning out to be an
inspired choice to play this irreverent
yet brilliant Pikachu oh my god you can
understand me but I've been so
though Reynolds had a rough few years as
an actor appearing in several box-office
flops his career was completely revived
by 2016 s Deadpool since playing the
foul-mouthed deeply sarcastic superhero
he's fully returned to Hollywood's
a-list now he's offering a new take on
Pikachu that could potentially help to
make the Mighty Mouse more popular than
ever in November 2018 some lucky viewers
got the chance to see a test screening
of Detective Pikachu and early reactions
have apparently been quite positive
audiences are specifically praised
Reynolds voice acting and his chemistry
which starred just two Smith the movie's
CGI effects also won some praise with
viewers describing them as being
extremely lifelike even though they
weren't quite finished yet test
screenings are followed this first roll
out of also reportedly garnered positive
responses what all of this means for
detective Pikachu precise potentially
good reviews and box office success that
it could also hold a rare distinction of
being a well received a live-action
video game movie a feat which has often
seemed impossible for Hollywood to pull
off from infamously bad films like Super
Mario Brothers and Street Fighter 2 more
recent and advised efforts such as
Assassin's Creed and Warcraft video game
movies are pretty much known for being
terrible but it's looking quite possible
that Detective Pikachu could break the
mold by becoming one of the first
live-action movies based off a video
game to earn widespread audience and
critical acclaim thanks to his
innovative CGI work audiences might
expect that Detective Pikachu was shot
with a heavy emphasis on motion capture
suits and green screen but as star just
a Smith told New York Magazine that
definitely wasn't the case according to
Smith the production made a point of
shooting on location as much as possible
using actual environments to help
enhance the reality of this live-action
Pokemon world filming took place in both
London and Scotland keeping green
screens to a minimum and using the
locations natural beauty and urban
backdrops to great effect director Rob
Letterman reportedly wanted to juxtapose
the fantastical world of Pokemon against
a gritty urban landscape to make the
creatures according to Smith pop more
also helping add the distinctive look of
the movie is the fact that it was shot
on film with the naturally grainy
quality helping to make the movie feel
like a realistic and gritty film noir
it's the source of small detail you
might not have noticed on its own
instead of viewers have just left with
the impression that the movie looks way
more realistic than they may have
expected in this
way another's detective Pikachu will
visibly set itself apart from any of us
animated predecessors in the Pokemon
series perhaps laying the track for a
whole new tradition for the franchise on
the big screen when the first trailer
for detective Pikachu dropped in
November 2018 audiences were both
confused and delighted compared to every
other Pokemon property it looked very
different but it also had a lot of charm
the first appearance of the title
character combining the cutesy look of
Pikachu with the quippy Ryan Reynolds
went over with viewers surprisingly well
before long a curious consensus started
growing
maybe the filmmakers has something here
the first trailer introduces a basic
story of Pikachu and Tim's quest to find
his missing father but it also made sure
viewers got glimpses of other Pokemon it
also made it clear that this Pikachu
would be a slightly more grown-up
iteration of the beloved children's
character getting adult fans who grew up
with a series more interested in the
movie than they might have expected they
would be the second trailer released in
February 2019
even more Pokemon alongside Pikachu
including the first glimpse of Muto the
menacing and hyper intelligent Pokemon
who headlined the series first animated
movie in 1998 the excitement and the
claim that Detective Pikachu's first
trailers kicked up has clearly been
encouraging to the people behind the
movie ahead of the film's release it's
already been announced that there's a
sequel in the works with a script being
written by Ori new zeal best known for
his writing credits on 22 Jump Street
the Cloverfield paradox and the upcoming
Sonic the Hedgehog whether or not the
director or start would return for a
sequel or what a sequel to the movie
would even be about it's still up in the
air but if detective Pikachu just well
enough with audiences at the box office
especially against the summer movie
juggernaut of Avengers endgame we
wouldn't be surprised if it kicked off a
whole new cinematic universe of
live-action Pokemon adventures for a
movie this off-the-wall and unexpected
that'd be a pretty shocking result check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]